I'm in awe she's just killing it she's
one of the more intentional people I've
ever met in my life Channing Tatum is
Zoe Kravitz's big GED fan no seriously
panning Acts actually follows his
girlfriend's fan accounts on Instagram
it's happening here we are before the
lovebirds made their relationship public
some eagle-eyed fans noticed that Chan
was following some Zoe Super Fan
accounts now the actor covers vanity
Fair's February issue and inside the mag
he weighs in on all that admitting that
he has no chill quote I was just seeing
what she was up to also I didn't know
anyone would know it came from a really
personal place the two first met after
he read an early draft of her flick P
Island Zoe had Channing in mind to play
the Island's owner a Sinister Tech
billionaire Zoe of course said that you
were her first choice for this film so
why were you shocked that you were asked
to play this part when you were her
first choice for the film without
reviewing certain things I definitely
don't play any one that I've ever played
before in this in this movie Channing
tells Vanity Fair that they love lost
touch after that meeting but two and a
half years later when Zoe had a new
draft of the script they reconnected and
Channing was impressed quote I was like
wow you are really saying something
that's the kind of person you want to
create with that really has this
perspective they're constantly digging
for Chan signed on for the project and
in 2021 the two sparked romance rumors
when they were spotted riding through
the streets of New York City on a joint
bike ride a few months later he
supported his leading lady at the
premiere of herflick the Batman
alongside Jason Momoa Zoe's stepdad the
two of your guys and your fam giving you
a shout out what does it mean to have
them in your corner giving you that
support well you know we're in New York
tonight and I live here I have a lot of
friends and family here tonight so I
feel very lucky to have a lot of people
who love to hear it and while they
haven't said a whole lot about their
love they haven't shied away from
praising each other's work Zoe makes her
directorial debut with Island and when
ET caught up with Channing last year he
admitted he advised Zoe not to direct
and star in the film something he did
with dog maybe we could have some fun is
that a deal shake
well I know you gave Zoe some advice on
it too is that what you said to her like
don't do both just direct I just don't
think you enjoy it like I didn't get to
enjoy really directing figuring out the
next shots and like what the next
decisions are and like what they're
getting and you know I'm sort of in my
own little world over there and I just I
I think that you need twice the time if
you're going to be in the movie and Zoe
told E.T she was glad she listened to
her man I'm absolutely not starring in
on in that film it's hard enough to to
act on on your own I don't know how
people do both I will not be in the
movie I'll just be directing it one
thing at a time so safe to say whether
they're collaborating in love or at work
these two are hashtag couple goals
[Music]